hello everyone and welcome to a really
amazing game from 2002 it's uh
11-year-old Magnus Carlson was rated
only 2125 at a time playing against the
high rated opponent Tor gulbranson at 2
2148 and he was Tor was uh 41 or 42 at
the the time this game was played uh
although this photo is much newer I
don't have access to an older one so
sorry about that but it's the game that
we are interested in and also I'm going
to sh some news with you regarding um a
certain tournament that will be coming
back but I'm going to talk about that
after the uh after we check out the game
so let's check it out Magnus with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to E4 and
this is a very very cool line that you
can play against the French defense that
if you if you struggle against the
French defense you are welcome to try it
it's a it's a really nice line so Pawn
to E6 the French defense D4 D5 and now
Knight to D2 and uh young Magnus did
face the the the French um of course
even before this game and he used to
play E5 he used to play Knight to C3 but
here he goes Knight to D2 it's pretty
much the same as it can transpose into D
captures um Knight captures but it also
can be different uh Knight to F6 the
closed tarash French and now Pawn to E5
Magnus advances the pawn attacks the
Knight Knight F to D7 Knight G2 F3 and
now Pawn to C5 and now of course you
know that black will put everything to
go after that D4 Pawn and you will
always struggle to defend it as you have
no idea how to do it but now young
Magnus will show you how to do it he
plays Pawn to C3 Knight to C6 and now
Bishop to D3 we have Queen to B6 putting
more pressure on the D4 pawn and Magnus
just gives it up he castles King side so
okay uh it's best to capture the pawn C
captures C captures Knight captures
Knight captures and queen captures um on
D4 okay um now Tor is up a pawn and
Magnus goes Knight Knight to F3 attacks
the queen and defends his E5 pawn queen
back to B6 but the queen is uh uh
optimally placed on B6 for the moment
hindering the development of the dark
Square Bishop as the B2 Pawn would hang
so it makes sense we have Queen to A4
Magnus develops the queen while uh
pinning that Knight and now Queen to B4
of course Tor is up a pawn he wants to
trade Queens Magnus says Nope Queen back
to C2 and he offers it again Queen to C5
Magnus declines again Queen to E2 uh and
now just Bishop to E7 preparing to
Castle Magnus goes Bishop to E3 of
course he wants to get as much
development in for the price of that one
Pawn so Bishop to E3 Queen back to A5
and now uh the position is still a most
theoretical one it's still being played
today and today top moves are A3 Rook a
to C1 you can play Maybe Rook F to C1 uh
but Magnus played Bishop to G5 and it is
not as of move 16 that this position has
never been repeated again which means
it's a unique game and uh it's not as
great a move as for example A3 or Rook a
to C1 the moves that are being played
nowadays but um it was 2002 you know
those were different times and the
reason why it's not so impressive is
that well uh not so impressive is maybe
maybe you know over stretching it a bit
you can play it because if black wants
to uh sort of overrule you and say that
this is a bad move black will have to
you know survive a devastating attack
but what I mean by this is that black
will have to Play Bishop captures and G5
and after Knight captures play H6 saying
okay just go back with the Knight and
then I'm going to Castle and everything
is fine but white can play Knight
captures on E6 that's the that's the
problem and then after captures you will
play Queen G4 attack G7 and E6 and now
if you want to play this precisely you
have to play Rook to f8 give up the E6
pawn and after King to d8 something like
B4 chasing the queen away from the
defense of the D5 Pawn let's say
captures or even Queen to C7 uh Queen
captures on D5 and okay you're up a
piece but I mean would you play this
with black against a Magnus Carlson uh
you know albe it an 11-year-old Magnus
Carlson but still so that's why after
this bishop to G5 move a capture did not
occur here we have Queen back to d8 now
just threatening to capture a full piece
and Magnus defends it Queen to E3 and
again you should just Castle here and
everything is perfectly fine you Castle
let's say captures captures Knight to G5
can be played but it doesn't really do
anything H6 kicks away the Knight and
you just have to go back Knight to H7
would be uh perhaps a bit too
adventurous so you just go back then
comes Knight to C5 and black is
perfectly fine but it seems that um Tor
here wanted to take advantage of his
younger opponent and he played Bishop
captures on G5 Knight Capt and G5 and
queen to E7 so uh what's the what's the
idea behind this queen to E7 move uh
he's uh checking if Magnus will capture
on H7 and if he does it looks like a
pretty good uh pretty great of course
you cannot play G6 here to trap the
Knight but you can play Queen to H4 and
now you either lose the Knight Rook
captures will will pick up the Knight
and Bishop uh for the price of the rook
and if you move the Knight of course
then just Queen captures on H2 will be
Checkmate so that's what he's hoping for
but Magnus just continues development
Rook a to C1 uh Pawn to H6 attacking the
Knight and now uh well now the move
Magnus played next might might surprise
you and I'm sure it will uh but just in
case you don't see it feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only move
for Magnus that wins the game on the
spot for white while I give you a couple
of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
figuring out that it has nothing to do
with this Knight I've only been you know
coloring it to you know confuse you and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Queen captures on A7
that's the move I'm even going to do it
in slow motion because it's such a such
a beautiful move to play and now you
realize the horror of what you've done
The Rook on A8 is undefended so you can
just ignore it and you can't capture the
White Queen if you capture the White
Queen then Rook captures and C8 with
check and that's it Queen d8 you're
going to capture the queen with check
and after King captures Knight captures
on F7 again with check and with a fork
you're going to lose the Rook as well
King E7 Knight captures on a h8 and
that's pretty much it okay you can take
the Knight but now Knight G6 check uh
sorry the pawn and then after let say
captures captures you will be uh you're
up a full Bishop you can capture a pawn
here but then after uh Rook defends the
pawn on B2 uh black is up a pawn but uh
White is white is up a full Bishop so
instead after Queen captures on A7 Tor
said all right uh my young adversary I
will I I will give you that it's a
wonderful move I'm just going to move
the Rook to B8 but young Magnus doesn't
care he sacrificed is the queen again
Queen captures on B8 and again it's a
big big trouble Knight captures on B8
has to be played otherwise you're just
down material and then Rook captures on
C8 is coming so Knight captures on uh B8
and now Rook captures and C8 with check
King to D7 and he picks up the other
Rook as well and now you have to decide
do you want to capture here and lose the
Knight on B8 or do you save the Knight
on B8 and then Magnus also saves the
Knight on F3 and now this is the
position it's only mve 24 and black can
pretty much resign because um he has uh
well Magnus has two Rooks and uh sorry
two Rooks and the bishop for the queen
which is too much material but still the
queen and Knight are a pretty good combo
maybe you can still do some damage so
Pawn to F6 but Magnus say nope Bishop to
B5 he wants to eliminate the Knight
right away and then black will be uh
counter playist if that is a word uh so
okay F captures on E5 we have Bishop
captures on C6 with check B captures
Knight captures on E5 with check King D6
and now Rook to E1 and uh now you can
just wait for the inevitable but it is
incredibly instructive how Magnus does
it uh King to C7 now comes Pawn to G3
okay you create some breathing room for
your king uh Queen to B4 putting
pressure on the rook and now Rook to E2
we have Pawn to D4 but now look at this
Rook to d8 this uh game is Just Magnus
impressing you move after move after
move now the the threat of course is
Rook to D7 with check uh which will you
know grab hold of the seventh Rank and
then maybe some you know especially if
the King goes up the board then maybe
some Rook D4 Rook to F4 Rook to f8
Checkmate that's magnus's idea and of
course if the Rook is captured a nice
Fork here Forks the king and the queen
uh you know just instant resigns so
Queen to B5 was played okay The Rook is
hanging The Rook is hanging but not to
worry Rook to D7 with check and now
where do you go uh King to B6 probably
the safest but then you go you know uh
in the center of the board with your
king so he decided to go up the board
which is uh well which is no better now
just Rook to E4 by Magnus and Rook to F4
Rook to f8 will be Checkmate there is
absolutely nothing you can do about this
Pawn to C5 was played maybe you should
even wait for it with this Pawn to C5
move because okay the The Rook still
cannot go to F4 as long as the queen is
attacking the Knight but he played Pawn
to C5 uh to well I guess the defended
the pawn and also to put pressure on
this Rook but it's still completely
irrelevant Rook to F4 by Magnus and
that's it Rook to f8 will be Checkmate
so he gave up the queen here but after
King captures on D7 he was in this
position on move 35 the Tor gulbranson
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here Magnus is up a full
rook and there is no there is no
counterplay here so brilliant stuff by
Young Magnus first sacrificing the queen
on A7 then sacrificing the queen on B8
then trying to sacrifice The Rook with
that Rook to d8 move I mean absolutely
amazing game and uh other than that
Bishop to G5 move which okay may not be
the most precise way to play you know
considering what the engine says now in
2024 uh even uh you you've seen what you
have to do in order to play this with
black you have to accept the the the pce
sacrifice but then I mean you will be
defending for the rest of the game if
that's your style feel free to play that
but it was not Tor gulbranson style so
he chose to go down the the other way
but yeah very nicely done by Magnus
thanks a lot to pav Roa Roa who um
suggested this game uh was a really a
wonderful suggestion so thank you for
that and also some news from the Chess
World like I said uh in some three days
time we will have that freestyle chess
goat challenge where Magnus will face
ding in chess 960 amongst other players
uh but the news I'm talking about is the
return of the grank chess classic but
this time it does not return as a
classical event it returns as a sort of
a slower rapid event where players will
be playing two rapid games of 45 minutes
per player per day and these are the
players that will be playing so Magnus
Carlson ding Len Maxim gra rard rort and
two German players Vincent KR and Daniel
fredman so it's going to be a pretty
pretty wild event where uh fredman as
the S sort of the the guest the the home
Hometown hero will be representing
Germany alongside Vincent CER but okay
Vincent is an incredibly strong player
but yeah it's going to be very very
interesting uh so we're going to see a
clash of Magnus and ding in in chess 960
in 3 days and then we're also going to
enjoy a clash between former and U
current world champion uh in in you know
normal chess but in in Rapid time format
uh so yeah that's the the game and the
News hope you enjoyed that I would like
to thank Jeremy anos Carl Weinberg rajas
chaoui branstone and D gasparian for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as you usual
you can check two of my previous videos
Sarah thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
enjoy games by Young Magnus do check out
the first link in the description below
uh it's it's a real treat see you soon